hello belief nation I made the mentor me
series to try to learn for people who
have done more than us to hang on them
just a little bit longer and hopefully
some of their magic dust rubs off onto
us to help us be more motivated be more
inspired and make greater changes in our
lives so today we're going to learn from
Gary Vaynerchuk on motivation
so at 30 I started Wine Library TV
YouTube blows up at 31 I'm on Conan
O'Brien Ellen there's articles being
written about me now they're writing
that the business grew from three to
sixty million dollars in sales I'm
becoming this guy I got so many goddamn
emails from friends in high school
during that period when I was showing up
in all these magazines and TV shows and
every single one of them was like hey
Gary you remember me from high school oh
my god you're so lucky
I wrote back every single one of them
and said let me just clarify one thing
I'm not lucky I worked I worked every
goddamn weekend at every holiday since I
was 14 years old so you can keep that
luck in your pocket
on my 30th birthday I looked myself in
my rearview mirror as I was driving from
New York to New Jersey and I said you're
not behaving to back up your own words
and eight weeks later I started Wine
Library TV on YouTube and started the
process of changing my career
I have massive empathy you know it's not
so awesome right now you're hoping for
that thing I get it I get it so much you
can't imagine I get 10,000 emails a day
like can't they just do this no you
can't it was so easy if it was so damn
easy don't you think we'd all choose
that it's a long game I was told between
7 years old and 18 years old that I lost
that I was a loser because this is what
I got F City baby but when I saw a city
I knew inside that this was not the game
that I was gonna play I was patient
I ate crow in that 12 year period while
the market and the Machine told me I
wasn't gonna win I you were my outcome
was and you may now be in their 20s and
30s and 40s and the Machine the
marketplace might be telling you that
you're gonna lose but it is about
staying the course and putting in the
work and position yourself in the right
position to go out and win you know why
I'm sitting here right now because I
outwork you zoom in I have worked you
what if I told you this was the last
Monday morning of your life what if I
told you you died this week would you
complain about your crap job or that
test you don't want to take I doubt it
you would go much higher level thinking
well that's really what it takes it
takes understanding that if you're not
pumped right now if you're begrudging
what you're about to do if you're if
you're not looking forward to it look I
respect practicality you got to go
through school because your parents want
to you got to pay your rent you got
student loans I get it but please
recognize the world we're living in
we're living in a world where there's so
much more opportunity this internet
thing created way more opportunity for
all of us way more I mean look you might
not even be alive like your mom and dad
could have had sex like three minutes
later and you wouldn't even exist and
you're complaining you could have ended
up being a bus a tree I just don't get
the mentality of being head down sad on
a Monday morning I'm gonna make Monday
morning my I'm gonna make you Saturday
Monday morning that's what I want to do
every morning and that's what I want
from you please take a step back and
think about how awesome it actually is
and then recognize that you can attack
the world in a totally different way
because you were lucky enough to be born
during this era
I have two calls right after I do this
video Phil Toronto from vayner/rse the
fund is coming and having a meeting that
was going to be at 11:30 p.m. tonight
he's coming to meet me at 1:00 basically
what I'm fascinated by is that people
like to say they hustle and I talk about
working the whole day and then I've
talked to you guys a lot about well it's
not about how much you sleep it's what
you do while you're awake and this is a
perfect example of something that I've
watched a lot of my contemporaries and a
lot of you the vaynernation right let's
say they love to hustle when something
happens come meeting gets canceled right
there's a curveball it's a snow day
right they take that as vacation time
instead of adjusting to it see the truth
of the matter is being efficient
executing shooting for those big goals
is predicated on your actions do you
take a extra-long lunch from jury duty
to say you know what cool I'm going to
chill and watch youtube videos or do you
hustle your face off and try to cram as
much in you know I I'm excited that
that's my first thought now look I get
it I'm sitting on a high chair right now
and talking down to like you should do
this I'm really not I'm really not
really not telling you what you should
do I'm really not trying to be a guru
I'm not really trying to be too cool and
say hahaha look at me not you I'm really
really really not really just making
these videos not for the people that you
find this condescending not for the few
people that find it motivational I'm
making this video for the people that
are foolish right the ones that tell me
to my face every day that yeah you know
and really want it and don't recognize
the actions that it takes to get there
so I'm making this video for a very
small percentage of you to the left look
no Gary thinks he's so cool to the right
that's the best time for complete
blindness no the middle the middle my
friends show many of you that actually
want this have the skills to do this
right and sometimes once in a while just
need to see a different version of it to
understand ah right ah to me this is an
AA video right did you mail it in did
you mail in that 15 minute 15 minute
call got cancelled you had a packed day
15 hour day they got cancelled what are
you doing at 15 minutes
and by the way sometimes those 15
minutes are absolutely worth calling
your mom calling your daughter FaceTime
with your kids but it's just making
every minute count every minute has to
count every minute has to count if you
want so much because you just don't have
as many of them as you think you just
don't
I think I'm good enough to win and I
think you're good enough to win at your
level am I gonna win at the ultimate
biggest guy of all time
gates sucks Buffett probably not I'm a
more charismatic than loving and more
interesting than those characters think
so
do I have enough to get me to a bill II
think so but is that 40 billion no are
you good enough to get to a hundred
thousand four hundred thousand I think
so just sat here read a hundred emails
from people that will make it 40 50 K 30
K read crushing read Thank You Connor
got inspired by me but I was a spark I
was the one that had that insane thing
that I have in me that made them say hmm
you know things that make you go home a
certain sorry but then they had it in
them and so when I make this video
what's coming from my heart right now is
maybe you're watching this and say hmm
maybe I need to hedge you know if you
work from 80 p.m. to 4:00 in the morning
will your dreams come true no you might
not be good enough you might have not
picked the right product but are we
living in a world 2012 that's so much
better than your parents and
grandparents and great grandparents
generation because [ __ ] like me can
make videos when I'm 30,000 feet in the
air
yes and because of that and because of
those opportunities because we're
networked in a way we've never seen
before because sending an email to 100
people on one will answer and give you a
shot matters because of that opportunity
because of 2012 I beg you I beg you to
take a shot roll up on that hot chick in
a bar and ask her out roll up on that
good-looking dude and ask him for coffee
roll up on your business idea and make
it happen because being 50 60 70
90 and having regrets that you didn't
swing the bat that's the worst of them
all our at-bat is in front of us take a
swing fire I see in the eyes of a 1920
25 year old that feels that they're
entitled to this and then on the flip
side the diminishing just a little bit
of ashes with a little smoke left on
that same entrepreneur when they were 22
at 46 when practicality and family
dynamics and the history and the market
tailing down and the lack of that same
opportunity has just Windell either down
to the moment where they don't believe
that they've got that shot and I'm here
to tell you you absolutely do I mean
they're absolutely a ton of
entrepreneurs that started their
companies in their 40s 50s 60s and 70s
when it was difficult to do such a thing
City Frank Ukranian Grey Goose and that
this big thing twin seventies and so
desperate I'm desperate to
to give you the springboard say you know
what instead of launching house of cards
seasons and instead of trying to you
know go to ball games or things of that
nature
yeah I do have 7:00 p.m. till 2:00 in
the morning Monday through Friday hack
for a lot of you the kids are out of the
house I mean let's get into practicality
for the late 40s 50 60 year olds that
are watching this round the kids are out
of the house like yeah you can pick up
golf or you can finally start that
candle company because you put pretty
pictures candles on Instagram and it
happens learn the craft figure out the
opportunity at hand go attack it you
only live once when you're 90 200 years
old and reading that you never build
this business and you let this era pass
this moment where there's so much
entrepreneurial outside
is the worst I mean until it is at least
the way I see it like I got home at
midnight last night and everything I
like it's just real like
why do I have to
so
I don't know I think there's a real
there's a real opportunity to to inspire
a generation that so deserves it like I
almost feel like that's being 40 I feel
like I'm caught in the middle like I
have so much empathy for I recognize how
insane I had to be to to like I mean you
can't even imagine how not practical
being an entrepreneur was when I was
your guys it like when I was happier age
like in school like like a 15 year old
now in school that's getting DS but it's
like selling [ __ ] on the Internet
everyone's I go there's our neck year in
the next Mark Zuckerberg and mine was
like yo you're the next pieces you know
like you know like it's so insanely
different and so I have a lot of empathy
for people that I don't know if they
recognize how real is thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I
hope you're extra motivated now I'd love
to know what you thought of this video
which of the clips or which of the
points that Gary made was most impactful
most insightful to you leave it in the
comments below and I'll join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon